yes trey gowdy is leaving Congress
apparently to spend more time with his
hair hi kid I like the guy but look at
him over the years got a mohawk goatee
sideburns then a beard and he adds
glasses and gets rid of the beard the
guy's more looks than Lady Gaga Sunday
Gowdy said he's leaving politics because
he's lousy at it I was a pretty good
prosecutor I think but I've been a
pretty lousy politician I see multiple
sides of a single issue and the fact
that someone disagrees with me does not
make me challenge their love of the
country it doesn't make me believe that
they're corrupt I've got a lot of
friends on the other side of the aisle
I think the manner in which we get
places matters and in politics too often
winning is the only thing that matters
and what every hero I have is lost every
one of them so losing is not the worst
thing in the world not knowing what you
believe and not caring enough about it
to fight for that's the worst thing in
them do you think now underneath that
cowlick
he has a point he's lamenting tribalism
the name-calling the smearing of
intentions by mind-reading adversaries
all driven by team sport politics take
the memo controversy it was the Super
Bowl for political point dexter's
everyone took sides even before reading
the damn thing of course no one in the
media seem to mind tribalism before when
only one side fought to win for the left
the politics was always personal and
deemed their opponents the right as evil
now the learner the right has learned
from the left and Republicans are now as
feisty as the lefties of old fueled by a
president who may be the least
ideological one I've ever seen the
results a fiery feedback loop where one
side accuses the other of divisive nough
stew endless counter accusations of the
same thing yet simply agree that we're
all guilty of this might help solve the
problem will that ever happen who knows
divisive miss is easy and its profitable
for it feels good to point a finger and
label people and if you disagree with me
you're probably a racist homophobic
later
that's true Kimberly what do you see him
going it's maybe a style segment on Fox
and Friends
I'm a fan of his I think he's really
bright he was phenomenal prosecutor had
a great reputation you know he handled a
large you know volume of material and
really stuck with it in terms of the
Benghazi hearings and you know I think
he's seen a virtuous person and I liked
what he had to say in terms of being
able to see all sides of an issue and
because someone disagrees with you
doesn't mean that they're a bad person
or their politics or their intentions
you know should be questioned so I'm
excited to see what he does next I don't
know maybe here I'm just lucky guy hey
you know data every time we hear about
the assessment of intensity and
tribalism every time I think about then
I think about the past we've had
assassinations in civil wars so is this
kind of is this idea that were being
divisive a bit overwrought I mean we did
have an actor kill a president you know
I remember when I talked to Mitch
McConnell last week he said let me put
everyone's mind at ease and he went back
and said you used to actually beat each
other up right on the on the floor and I
think that trey Gowdy seems very
relieved this is a decision that he's
wrestled with for the last couple of
cycles because he realized I think early
on that well this might not be for me
there's a lot of different ways that you
can serve your country and be a public
servant and you don't always have to run
for office it's the endless fundraising
the inability to actually do what he
wants to do which is the law but he is
somebody that you would certainly want
as your own personal lawyer if you if he
decides to go into law I mean is that
baby want him as a neighbor or a teacher
or a friend a little bit as well like a
neighbor ever since the Benghazi
hearings when he would be willing to
talk to you yeah you didn't have to and
he would just give it to you straight
that was certainly welcome and different
no wonder he didn't fit in it's good you
know a good member of a book club too
don't you think I think we're going too
far here why I think the the conflict is
heightened because Republicans have
learned from the Democrats on how to
fight don't you think that's true
you guys were broke you guys throw in
the 60s
we're so you disagreed with was evil out
more let's go back to the Civil War but
I'm just the Democrats right yeah so I'm
slavery but I don't see I mean to me
trey gowdy you know by the way I think
very competent prosecutor but what he
did during Benghazi two years a beatin
up on Hillary Clinton and then come in
and conclude there's nothing here I mean
I don't understand it
I like the fact that he now says you
don't have to you know turn your
opponent's into Devils I think boy but
now he's leaving and he's won by the way
Jesse unbelievable to me but forty one
Republicans who aren't are leaving this
Congress nine committee chairmen
including people like trey Gowdy who
does have respect as I say I don't like
what he did with Benghazi but he does
have some respect as a man who knows the
law a man who could have been one of the
president Trump's considerations for
attorney general but now you see all
these people flee and guess why they're
fleeing there's an erratic president and
there's a chance the Democrats are going
to have a big November this year Jesse
can you tie this into the Superbowl yeah
I don't think I don't think gaudi's
leaving because he's gonna lose his seat
no so I like the hair shots could we put
the six hair shots back I want to pick
my best one I think the one on the upper
left if you want a DVR in fact was
probably the best look there it is right
there with the scruffy good tea insert
the the Benghazi hearings Juan just said
that you know nothing ever came of it
basically we found out that they didn't
protect the consulate on the E on 9/11
anniversary couldn't save our own men
and women because they didn't have
assets in place and then lied to the
American people and to the victims
families to their face and said it was
about a video when they knew all along
there was a terrorist attack I actually
think he got to the bottom of that I he
looked relieved because all you do is
dial for dollars I heard they like put
you in a room for like four hours a day
and you fundraise that sounds terrible
I'm in the swamp stinks I'd want to get
out of it - he's probably going to get a
nice paycheck pretty soon